I'd like to welcome you all here today
this afternoon for today's today's
speaker the that's Pavan sukhdev who is
the study leader of here and a new
McCluskey fellow and who's here partly
for the Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies and you know I
occasionally watch television and on
sunday i saw the PBS series nature where
they were they had a program on the
ecosystems of cuba and well i see some
not some other people are watching TV at
the same time i was and what was
remarkable about this this program is
that Cuba has many relatively unspoiled
ecosystems left there as a artifact of
its relative isolation from world
markets for about since the Beatles
first took up their guitars and that
that that you know the program of course
showed all the the ecosystems in the
unspoiled glory and efforts how on a
shoestring you know biologists and
wildlife ecologist in Cuba we're trying
to study it and to preserve it and a
sense of apprehension that they all felt
because as everyone knows within a few
years the global market will come to
Cuba and and these ecosystems will be
under stress but then you ask yourself
is it an axiom is it axiomatic that
there is this conflict an unavoidable
conflict between the global economic
system and ecosystems together and that
is partly the subject of today's talk
and life work of today's speaker Pavan
sukhdev who is a senior banker at
a bank with their global markets
division he's currently also working
with the united nations environmental
program to lead their green economy
initiative and he's put out a series of
reports under the unfortunate acronym te
eb teeb sounds a little bit like an
enzyme to me but it stands for the
economics of ecosystems and biodiversity
and I must emphasize here that that dr.
suka dev is a a banker he is a bona fide
a innovative actor in the global
economic system is responsible for
several tradable securities that have
partly drawn India into its proper place
in the world the world market or for
capital movement and formation and so he
comes to environmental concerns with one
foot in the global economy with a clear
understanding of a practical solutions
to some of the environmental problems
that we face and is going to help tell
us in a larger context some of the
reasons not to fear the opening of Cuba
to global markets dr. sue
thank you Jeff for that lovely
introduction to my challenge for the
next 45 minutes or an hour and let me
first agree with you that I also think
he was a horrendous acronym and and I
wish we had called this project 10 the
economics of nature so much easier come
trips off the tongue so much more easily
and its reports would have been
published in 2010 at the convention on
biological diversity as they were last
year in the area and it would be cop 10
which would be receiving these reports
so in hindsight it made a lot of sense
to this but of course unfortunately I'm
not that clever I didn't think of this
until last year which was a bit too late
it is unfortunately known as T with the
economics of ecosystems and biodiversity
it's a mouthful I'll come back to that
point in a few moments when Tom
approached me for this this speech I
said sure they happy to speak for you
anytime but what about and he says oh
well give us a few options so I wrote
him an email with a few options some
green economy some about wealth
accounting and valuation for ecosystem
services a new world bank project and a
few others and I said well there's this
other thing called what's the world
worth you know a little bit cheeky so he
says yeah I like that one so this is the
reason why you have today a session
which I call what's the world's worth so
let's ask this question what is it worth
so the world of course is the biosphere
right so to think both is worth you need
to first check out a world without a
biosphere some of you would recognize
Mars no biosphere no species that we
particularly know off or care for and no
human beings no exchanges between human
beings no economy zero is the size of
the economy there and move away and we
come to a different world which you are
familiar with where there is a biosphere
and there are species and they're even
cell phones and and they're certainly
exchanges economic exchanges and there
is if you like one economy well to go
from one to the other basically the
answer is one economy minus zero economy
/ 0 economy
1-0 / 0 is basically infinity that's it
thank you very much bye it's rapin okay
so where's the drinks then no so i will
i will now tell you what the real
subject of this is about the economic
invisibility of nature and that's really
what I'd like to speak with you about
before we do that I just like take a
little detour and and show you a movie a
very short movie of about a minute which
was made for us by some young filmmakers
this is by the way a movie of three
which one was selected for some awards
as good ways of communicating to people
what is this all about the value of
nature and why is economic invisibility
of nature a problem and what needs to be
done and so on this was a competition
run for aspiring ad film makers and I'm
delighted to say that we submitted these
three movies and one of them not this
one actually even though I like this one
a prize which was at their own film
festival in November last year so here
we have something which talks about the
value of nature
so a little a little brutal but I think
it gets the point across and this this
is what T biz about it deep the
economics of ecosystems and biodiversity
is not just about compiling as we have
done in a scholarly tome written by a
collaboration of almost 80 economists
and ecologists on the economics of
ecosystems but it's also about
presenting the results of this work to
people who matter and the people who
matter and make decisions are
policymakers administrators at the local
level businesses and individuals and
wisely we were advised do not write a
book for people for God's sakes they
don't read make films so this is this is
what we did instead so let me now get
back to the talk that wasn't and talk to
you about what this room was about which
is the economic invisibility of nature
why it's a problem and why we need to
end it well firstly of course nature of
the biosphere numerous beautiful
ecosystems amazing species and diversity
and genetic material the picture here
which you recognized as the Amazonian
rainforest too many a place of
incredible species diversity but beyond
that also a massive carbon store because
tropical forest like this
in fact provides significant climate
change benefits mitigation services if
you like tropical forests cover almost a
fourth of terrestrial carbon and they
also are providing a mitigation service
in terms of capturing carbon a recent
studies have shown that peak forest
fanuc forests are actually absorbing
carbon literally from the atmosphere
farming carbon dioxide as as their their
manure so to speak and that accounts for
something like 5 or 4.8 gigatonnes of
carbon dioxide capture every year which
means there's almost fifteen percent of
total emissions of of co2 and that's a
very significant mitigation engine but
of course do we conserve them and make
use of them for that no we are losing
tropical forests quite significantly
still due to deforestation a study was
done the alias review a couple of years
back which estimated the value of having
before a station was of the order of
three or four trillion dollars and with
that element of of economic opportunity
or benefit if you like in stopping
deforestation the question needs to be
asked why doesn't it happen and of
course the problem is no one pays for
this mitigation service but not only
that this same rainforest is also a
water pump it is actually providing
thanks to the precipitation that comes
from the northeastern trade winds as as
they produce rainfall which is seeded by
almost 20 billion tons an estimated 20
billion tons of water river water
evaporation into the into the atmosphere
from the Amazon as rain forests they are
basically providing the water supply for
the entire laplata basin and its
agricultural economy of several hundred
billion dollars worth and then the
question has to be asked well does
Uruguay Paraguay Argentina or for that
matter does the state of mato grosso pay
anything to the state of amazonas for
this fresh water supply and the answer
is no at once again the answer is zero
so as we explore this whole point about
the services of nature these so-called
ecosystem services again and again and
again across this entire spectrum of the
three tiers of what is
in CBD language called biodiversity the
ecosystem level the species level the
genetic level if you look at all of the
attributes that is the extent the
abundance of the population on the one
hand and the diversity on the other and
we look at what's provided be it
recreation and water regulation carbon
storage from ecosystems or be it food
fuel fiber and pollination services from
species by the way there is a study done
on global pollination services which
estimated the value of pollination
services as of the order of 150 billion
euros that's about nearly 200 billion
u.s. dollars which is nearly eight nine
percent of the total agricultural output
of the world well all of these are are
essentially other than a few exceptions
like food which is priced and timber
with this price all of these services
tend to be in the nature of public goods
and services and most of them are
provided free and that's the challenge
most of nature services are economically
invisible and if and when as we do lose
these services we have to think about
the the failed economic thinking that
goes behind looking at markets as the
only means of pricing and recognizing
that there are ways of recognizing value
and appreciating value and demonstrating
value which do not necessarily rely on a
market price and why we don't go there
is is really something that we need to
address I illustrate the point of
looking at trade-offs in economics with
this simple example which is from a
study done by at Barbie and others from
South Island and here in in this area as
in many parts of Southeast Asia there
has been a continuous degradation of the
mangrove bells because of deep of
conversion into shrimp farms and the
logic is economically that a typical
hectare of rainforest off of mangrove
forest if converted into a shrimp from
over a nine-year period which they
selected in that study produces a value
of something like nine and a half
thousand dollars but the same places
were left as a mangrove swamp and just
providing fuel would benefits to local
communities would be worth only about
six hundred dollars
but what that comparison obviously would
fail to pick up is that most of the
money that is being produced the
so-called profits of shrimp farming are
actually subsidies local government
subsidies so the comparison is not not
that significant and also what that
comparison has failed to look at because
the lens being used was that of just
private profits is that there is a cost
to land use of converting a mangrove to
a shrimp farm because salt deposition
and chemical depositions over time make
that land unusable even for shrimp
farming so somebody has to pay for costs
of restoration or at least recognize
that there is a cost of restoration and
that cost is estimated as something like
12 thousand dollars and on the flip side
the mangrove provides coastal protection
storm and cyclonic defense which was
estimated at about twelve thousand
dollars so the real comparison if we
account for public benefits and not just
private profits the real comparison is
not between plus nine thousand and plus
600 but actually is more like minus
eleven thousand and plus twelve thousand
so the trade-off choice that you'd make
with this payoff diagram is obviously
the opposite of what you make with this
that's using the lens of just private
profits that's using the lens of total
wealth once again this is the issue of
the Commons the tragedy of the Commons
but a small example but unfortunately it
is just a small example because a study
recently showed that if we looked at the
listed companies this was a study
constructed bottom up so it's literally
company by company done by a group
called true cost they came to a
staggering answer that there was
something like 2.2 trillion dollars
worth of externalities in other words
social costs borne by society as a
result of global businesses doing
business as usual and that's he which we
are talking about almost three percent
of the global GDP and that's not eating
the end of the story because that's just
the top three thousand companies if you
take all private corporations then the
answer is almost twice that so I think
the first reason why we must end the
economic invisibility of nature is
because just calling it an externality
is not good enough these days it
is huge it is just too significant even
in economic terms in estimated economic
terms for it to be just ignored as a
marginal issue but it goes beyond that
let's take coral reefs for example now
the question to be asked if this is the
Great Barrier Reef and that's tiny
helicopter values to give you a sense of
scale picture taken by Leonardo spectral
to I'm grateful to him for having
provided his amazing library of slides
free to team as indeed with the T
project you find a remarkable community
feeling people come to this project with
an appreciation that yep the economic
invisibility of nature's a problem you
guys are working on this can we help and
that's very much been the story of team
it's very much a collection of
economists ecologists religious social
anthropologist government servants
politicians businessmen who are
basically working on the same problem
how do we fix this well sorry coming
back to the point I was making with
coral reef so the question is beyond the
beauty and ends and spiritual value in a
sense of coral reefs as sources of
inspiration are there social
implications and the study was done
recently which estimated at almost 500
million the number of people who are
dependent on coral reefs through
fisheries the fact that corals are the
seeding round of nurseries of fish and
through tourism and through related and
ancillary activities there's almost half
a billion people who in some way or the
other across these populous areas of of
Asia Pacific Islands Indonesia Malaysia
the Philippines coming across all the
way to Madagascar the Andaman Islands
and the whole of the Caribbean there's a
huge population of people who are not
necessarily wealthy not necessarily with
options of livelihood who depend upon
the fisheries and the tourism and the
ancillary industries around these and
that dependency is huge can you just
imagine that if absent these coral
fisheries what options would they have
the Philippines today actually has plans
to attend it has estimated there is
something like
25 million people out of its population
of 80 million who are susceptible to
this kind of dislocation and it's quite
difficult to suggest that alternative
employments and livelihoods locations to
live and food can easily be provided in
the absence of coral reef fisheries and
as you know corals are a species an
entire ecosystem at risk if there is any
ecosystem today which is at a threshold
of the potential collapse it's the cause
because of this combination of factors
leading from carbon dioxide emissions
not only is warming more more than
likely to create more events of the kind
of the bleaching that took place in 98
but also the increasing acidity of
oceans of the declining alkalinity of
oceans due to the absorption of that
carbon dioxide makes it more difficult
for aragonite to form and to regenerate
a coral reef after it's been pleased so
there's a double whammy acting against
the corals thanks to increasing carbon
dioxide concentrations so there is a
serious risk here which is not just an
entire ecosystem but also the half
billion people who are dependent on that
ecosystem another another area where
this comes up quite starkly is if we
look at forests and the role that they
play in supporting poverty and typically
when we look at forest ecosystem
services and if we were and it's it's
it's just a comparison which is for for
the sake of comparison if we lower to
look at ecosystem services and their
values in three countries India
Indonesia and Brazil we find the range
is in terms of size these services are
valued at between ten and twenty percent
of the GDP s of these countries so you
might be forgiven for ignoring them
because you know even GDP is inaccurate
and it's an estimate and so on but the
reality is that if you look at specific
populations who are dependent on these
ecosystems absent the forests the people
who suffer floods and droughts are
basically subsistence farmers have sent
the forests the the wives who cannot
collect fuelwood more than six forty
percent in across the world and sixty
percent in in these countries who depend
on fuel wood in India for instance are
basically the lives of the persistence
farmers and agricultural should live in
and around for us and of course I've
sent the forest cattle and goats cannot
graze off the leaf litter so once again
the the dependencies are very strongly
in the area of smallholder farming and
these populations are massive 350
million in India 99 million in amisha
these are estimates made by three
studies done for team to look at what is
the ecosystem service dependency of poor
households and if we work out their
total household incomes and instead of
just doing a rather simplistic divides
services by GDP we say divide services
consumed by the poor as a fraction of
their livelihood incomes then that
answer is is much higher we are talking
about half to ninety percent and that's
actually a critical factor to appreciate
that the invisibility of nature is not
just a generic overall problem society
but it's a particularly sharp problem in
terms of development strategy and
development paradigms because if we fail
to appreciate this and then our entire
development model if it is relying for
instance too much on trickle down or
relying too much on built infrastructure
may not even achieve the purposes for
which it was designed and that's a
challenge that we have to address so I
would then say that the second and
additional reason why we must try to end
the economic invisibility of nature is
that business as usual nature losses
will perpetuate poverty it will not it
is not possible in my opinion to change
or alter the livelihoods of so many
people we are talking about 1.2 billion
who are dependent on land based
ecosystems forestry and dependent
through subsistence agriculture on on
these all these ecosystems it's quite
difficult to imagine alternative
livelihood solutions for such a large
population in any reasonable span of
time so teeb and it's five reports which
were presented at the at the cop ten
meeting last year in Nagoya really is
about looking at solutions I think in
our initial report the interim report
published way back in 2008 we did rely
on a few studies done to
estimate the size of the the economic
size if you like of the losses in other
words the human welfare impacts of these
losses and we compile that and as a
demonstration of the significance of the
problem the economic significance of the
problem of losses but what we've done
with the phase two of the team project
is to actually look at solutions and
that's what the rest of my conversation
today with you is about which is looking
at various solutions and how they work
and why they work and why they don't
work in some cases so we have actually
written the tape reports very much with
an end user in mind with the decision
maker in mind and written separately for
the scientists and economists separately
for policy makers separately for
business people and separately for local
governments and when we talk valuation
and I think that was if you like the
serious point behind behind my my
flippant start to this session when we
talk about valuation we are not actually
talking about Cuba and converting it
into a tradable commodity in terms of
its amazing ecosystems but we are
talking about valuation as a human
institution that's exactly the words
from the tee book this is John Lindsay a
chapter on valuation is lead author not
by an economist not buyin ecologists but
by eduardo bronze easier who's in fact
social anthropologist and he looks at
valuation in the broad context of how
societies value and valuation as a
feedback mechanism into society
valuation is something that works at a
spiritual level at a societal level you
can recognize value in many different
ways and there are many countries with
communities which place if you like the
ultimate value to forest because they
consider them sacred forests that you
cannot put a price on that at all it is
valuable because it's sacred period end
of discussion and there are other
communities such as here in the US where
areas of human heritage have been
declared to be reserves and national
parks for over a century sorry more than
a century and a half in fact so clearly
at that point the economics of the
cemetery National Park were not
considered it was just you know one
amazing place and so on and likewise in
other parts of the world so human
society does respond to value
appreciates value in response to value
without any reference
economics and that's fine that is
perfectly acceptable it can also respond
to demonstrating value and it can also
respond to capturing value sometimes you
can just demonstrate and have policy
change so Teebs approaches to look at
valuation in totality and not just to
look at a fraction of the valuation
space so therefore we have identified
basically five different broad
categories of strategies in the form of
reflecting ecosystem services the value
that ecosystems deliver in regional and
planning reflecting ecosystem services
in legislative change in terms of for
example new protected areas or or
changing the way that you access
protected areas reflecting it in
certification eco certification and eco
labeling which is a combination of
policy and business reflecting it in in
payments for ecosystem services indeed
the report of team which is the red
covered report I shall when we when we
go for drinks I'll bring up some copies
for you people to pick up of these
reports there at least the executive
summaries which are all very slim the
reports themselves are somewhat massive
and they are on the website but there
are copies of the executive summaries
available so we address in the tea for
local governments more than a hundred
and twenty case studies of policy action
local policy action which has in some
way or the other either recognized value
or demonstrated value and made use of
any one or more of these strategies and
i'll talk to you about some of my
favorites but the other point I'd like
to make before I go on to the examples
is that these same strategies actually
span a whole host of operating spaces
because in terms of regional and
planning and legislation we are talking
about policy and regulation in terms of
certification and protected area
evaluations we are talking about at
least an economic assessment if not an
economic mechanism and then finally in
payments for ecosystem services these
are mechanisms where a party pays or
parties pay and another party receives
so you are internalizing the externality
you're capturing the value and then of
course there are markets and I wouldn't
call a payment for ecosystem service a
market because there's usually 11
and one seller of one community that's
buying and selling but there are also
markets that are biodiversity markets
that I there are wetland banking markets
right here in the US so there are also
market solutions but please don't and
this is my response to not just Cuba but
also Bolivia and Venezuela because they
keep thinking that somehow teeb is about
just parceling their country into pieces
and selling it but that's not because
because the market square if you like is
actually a subset of a subset of a
subset of valuation and and that's
putting market solutions in perspective
I'm not dismissing markets editions they
can be very effective at times but they
are not the only solution and it is not
possible to put prices to everything or
indeed to to believe that the market
solution is the best in some cases it
may not be the best howsoever defined so
let me pick these five strategies that I
talked about and talk to you about my
favorite examples of these in terms of
regional and planning the boxing county
in in China actually redrafted its its
land use master plan using the invests
of twere and going through as you can
see in this diagram a very detailed
mapping of where valuable ecosystem
services were coming from so they did
have a significant amount of development
land use change as part of their County
plan but that it was sensitive to where
were the areas of biodiversity and
ecosystem services so they were
sensitive to nature as a result of
making use of this software for their
mapping in terms of legislations and
once again legislations which did not go
into the economics in detail but i think
the legislation of the Tabata reefs
national park in the Philippines is a
very interesting example because it came
about as a result of the bleaching event
in 98 and a stakeholders meeting that
was organised including fisher folk and
ngos and the governments and came about
with the idea that there should be a
no-go zone to be able to allow the reefs
to recover their fisheries value and
very goo tourism value and that no-go
zone was subsequently increased a few
years later by almost double
and the results are there for people to
see that you are seeing an increase in
live coral cover in this area and you
are seeing almost four-fold increase in
the amount of fish an example of a
protected area evaluation are once again
i emphasize no money has changed ending
in either the reef coral reef case but
it's now we're getting into the economic
calculations and here was a wetland
outside the city of Kampala that is
Uganda's capital which was slated to be
damned and and converted to additional
land to the use for agriculture until an
economist did a study which demonstrated
that the value of the wetland as a as a
sewage treatment plant effectively as a
natural sewage treatment plant for the
city of Kampala was about 2 million
dollars whereas the alternative value of
that land in neta net of the costs of
conversion was scarcely over 250 or 300
thousand dollars so leaving the wetland
as a sewage treatment facility for the
city was actually economically seven
eight times more valuable than
converting it and that argument that
economic argument apparently did have
sway and subsequently been a key global
swamp has been included in a green belt
and delighted that is still still there
another benefit of keeping the swamp as
it was was that the livelihoods of the
local fisher folk because this is an
active swamp the livelihoods of the
local fisher folk were also retained so
here's an example where evaluating an
area and just demonstrating the value
once again no money changing hands as
such but demonstration of value made a
difference and i have a final example
here which is from japan where the
conference was held last year one of
their so-called satyr yama which is
basically landscapes which are eco
social landscapes as they call them the
white stock the oriental white stock had
gone locally extinct in the in Honshu
Island in the area close to the city of
toyoko and Ryoga city decided to cap
keep a few breeding pairs
from the US from Russia and made use of
a change in farming practices starting
to farm on the basis of wet paddy in
winter not just dry paddy because that
is with wet paddy you get the frogs and
other species that the stock feeds on so
they were able to effectively
reintroduce the livestock with just
about 200 hectares of of organic rice
and wet paddy in winter so a change in
system led to a species reintroduction
which was dear to the people of Toyota
city it had other benefits it thanks to
the introduction the means of the
introduction was actually an incentive a
payment for the ecosystem services so
they actually paid 40,000 yen per
thousand square meters of organic
farming to offset the additional cost of
the farmers would face of wet paddy in
winter and they also supported a
certification scheme so that those
farmers who used this organic farming
practice or this eco eco friendly
practice depending on how much could be
certain could certify their ice as white
stock rice and that certification
combined with this organic farming
fetches prices of between twenty and
fifty percent higher in the Japanese
market place because it gave the
association of good practice with that
farming so it's been a successful
experiment is still very much in what I
would describe I've been down there I
actually seem to breeding pairs of white
stock so it is it is true it's not a
story but it struck me as much more a
sort of hobby farming because the people
there were not poor farmers there was
just normal city folks who were doing
farming anyway and they decided to have
a patch in that particular area which
led to the reintroduction of the white
stock so this hobby farming success has
had other positive externalities and
that there is an eco-tourism center on
the white stock has been built which
collectively earns through its visitors
and and fees and so on something like 10
million dollars a year and that's huge
and the benefits to the prefecture have
been significant wave actually that
they've actually the city municipalities
incomes have increased by one point four
percent which if anyone is familiar with
the economy of Japan is actually a big
number it's not a small number
these examples that I give you are
amongst a hundred plus examples that are
there of local success stories around
the world and which are on this website
the Europa Atlas website is called it's
very straightforward anyone from here is
interested can log in there go to
whatever interest view and for example
if you take the community forestry in
Nepal if you click in there you'll see a
bit more detail in terms of what it's
about and if you click in further than
you'll see a whole page or two pages of
text which describe the project the
policy context the economics and
hopefully our purpose here is to
encourage our purpose here is to
demonstrate that there are solutions
that they work and there are working
solutions at at local level which are
addressing particular problems of
ecological loss and environmental
degradation and reversing those losses
through constructive means of changes in
policy and incentives and PE s and land
use plan management and so on and so
forth on the commercial side as well
there seems to be a few changes
happening of course you're all familiar
with the the fact that the organic
industry is still showing remarkable
growth certified plunger project
products basically forest certified and
marine certified MSC certified fish are
amazing success stories and forest
certification is increasing by leaps and
bounds and we have of late the store
chain called Sainsbury's in the UK
announced that it will only sell MSC or
farm fish period no no ocean which fish
at all and that's a remarkable decision
for for a commercial outfit which is
quite significant in the UK market place
in addition there any number of leading
names like Mars and Cadbury and crafts
and Unilever who've taken on board rain
forest certification or forest
certification quite seriously as part of
that product suite and not just
consumers but also investors are looking
at biodiversity as as a source of new
business when I was in Japan I learned
that Sumitomo Bank had created a new
fund the biodiversity fun
looking at companies which do all kinds
of things which either biodiversity
positive or looking at problems and
solving problems some bizarre companies
there was one company in this fund which
actually created artificial coral reefs
by some form of electrolytic stimulation
it was quite interesting to see its
demonstration project but they're also
companies which are in organic farming
business and certification business and
so on but they are basically looking at
companies which have a focus on nature
on restoring nature or or responsibly
using nature and putting those companies
into a separate fund so clearly there is
some interest even on the Investor side
so i think this combination of examples
of local success stories of policy
driven success more than 100 of them on
our website across the world and quite a
few commercial success story suggests
that there is a rationale there is a
rationale to look at moving away from
economic invisibility simply because
there are so many solutions why not
address a problem if you can see
solutions dwelling on that theme for a
bit more we can go away from thinking of
all of the damage and loss that is
taking place in nature from a negative
point of view but looking at it more
positively I think the community the
environmental community and indeed the
biodiversity community probably does
itself a disservice by just speaking too
much of the problems and not enough of
the solutions and I see it differently I
think you need to recognize and
appreciate risks and losses but at the
same time you need to address
opportunities and if we look at
typically what we talk about carbon
dioxide emissions as a problem but at
the same time we need to see that bio
carbon offsets and and red plus are huge
potential solutions waiting around the
corner I was interviewing someone today
was young lady here working on a biochar
project as a as a new a new company
there are estimates of red plus vs.
which suggests that that could be a ver
shears and Rekha hello vidisha so there
are there are solutions on red plus
which are available being tested around
the world and there are estimates which
I received or a potential for red class
as a potential thirty to a hundred
dollar marketplace that's not small by
any measure of course we are concerned
about habitat disperse disturbance and
conversion and on the flip side then we
have biodiversity offsets and
conservation banking solutions water use
and freshwater security is a huge
problem around the world but at the same
time we do have payments for ecosystem
services out of 100 plus examples that I
I mentioned in our team for local
governments there are 25 examples of
freshwater payments for ecosystem
services and the marine footprint is a
problem and I will spend a few moments
now talking about that but then of
course we can look at marine
certification and good old-fashioned
conservation protected areas marine
protected areas as an economic solution
and of course pollution and waste does
have an industry behind it there's
recycling there's waste management
there's tradable permits for waste and
so on and so forth but let me just dwell
a bit on the fisheries issues because
fisheries is both a huge challenge for
us today and Fisheries is also an
remarkable example of economics good
economics not being applied first a few
words in just a few words on the problem
because it does have so many dimensions
it's not just the fact that you know we
are by various accounts fishing down the
food web and depleting fish stocks at a
level which is unsustainable at a rate
which is unsustainable which will
potentially lead to a loss of an
industry which is 8590 billion dollars
worth of landed catch of marine
fisheries but beyond that is the 30 odd
million jobs that are at risk because as
these stocks get depleted especially the
the poor fisher folk who are who are
affected there's of 35 1,000,000 about
30 million of those jobs are basically
artisanal or poor fisher folk who are
dependent on these fisheries for their
personal survival and for taking that
fish to the local market so there's a
huge equity problem here in terms of the
way that these these losses are are
being driven and please note that the
main drivers of these losses the over /
fishing in the seas is basically open
access which is the design of the
the global laws the UN Convention for
the law of the Seas open access on the
one hand and which leads to the tragedy
of the Commons and also subsidies
because we have something like twenty
seven the latest estimate was twenty
seven billion dollars of subsidies
largely which are leading towards
increasing fleet capacity so that
trollers can fish further and fish
deeper and actually exacerbate the
problem now those of you are from the
economics profession will understand
that we are all about scarce resources
but the scarce resource and therefore we
should be investing in scarce resources
but the scarce resource here is fish the
scarce resource is not fishing capacity
and yet that's exactly what we are
investing in and guess what it's your
taxes and my taxes that are being used
to invest in even more fishing capacity
a colleague of mine Rashid sumaila is
from British Columbia he wrote in our
chapter on the green economy on
fisheries that he estimated that over
capacity and fishing was between 180 and
200 eighty percent and yet we are
investing in more fishing capacity it
just defies logic here's a calculation
which comes to you from a study done by
the World Bank in the Food and
Agricultural organization and what
they've calculated is the increase in in
fishing capacity that is taking place
and at the same time it declined a
simultaneous decline in the catch per
unit capacity so the net effect of these
two trends increasing capacity and
decline in cash is actually nothing just
multiply one by the other you just get F
no change so all that's happened is a
static situation with more effort being
spent with bigger fleets and greater
capacity to fish the same amount of fish
and the economic underutilization that
is taking place here the under
optimization is basically estimated
about fifty billion dollars so just
think of these numbers fifty billion
dollars of economic inefficiency 27
billion dollars of your money and mind
being paid in subsidies effectively to
this industry and total landed catch of
85 billion dollars i mean if there is a
better example of global economic
stupidity i'd like to be told what that
is but this is my my vote for this
candidate
but the good news is that apparently
there are solutions and I am told by I'm
not a scientist I'm told by the experts
that if you look at marine protected
areas there is a very strong rationale
why they do work which is that female
fish as they grow twice the size they
could produce ten to a hundred times as
many eggs and you just need to have
patience and have transition plans
because you will have losses in
communities which are fig fishing
communities who have one unable to
access those those waters during the
time that you are rebuilding fish stock
so you do need some money set aside for
that but certainly not as much as twenty
seven billion dollars and in fact
rasheed's estimates were that something
like 300 billion dollars a total
investment would be sufficient to
address the fleet capacity downsizing
concerns and to be able to generate in
his in his estimation value of stock
which is almost five times as much
compared to the investment in capacity
downsizing and transition support for
livelihoods of communities or fishing
communities let's look at an example and
see whether this theory holds or not so
this is actually from not that far away
this is off Georges Bank the fishing
area and these these dots these colored
dots are actually satellite measurements
of the vessel ours the best because
there are no go zones such as this
triangle this one this rectangle in this
rectangle since there are no go zones
vessels have to carry satellite
identification satellite readable
identification and you can map how long
they've been in these various areas and
in this in this map what you see is
those blue areas where they are not very
much and the other colors in yellow
green and orange and so on where they've
spent more hours and of course you can
see that in the no-go areas generally
speaking there is no fishing well of
course you know by mistake I'm sure a
few people wandered into this into this
yard there are a few dots inside but I
mean the point could be made by a
fishing community set see mr. so where
we told you this we are losing
likelihoods and there's almost none of
us here and definitely none of us here
and we are right and you are wrong but
then i invite you to look at this small
triangle in greater magnification and so
here's the next picture again satellite
which is this
all of the fishing is taking place guess
what at the rim at the edges of the
protected areas because of course nobody
told the fish that this is a protected
area so they wanted 11 without and they
get a nicely caught by the by the that
the nets the nets of the waiting fishing
fleets all of the heavy fishing is in
that area evidence if any is needed that
yes the theory does work fishery
stalking does happen and it is
commercially valuable so it is a
commercially valuable activity to look
at marine protection as an investment in
the scarce resource fish not Motorola's
please not more fishing capacity going
away from fish although i'd love to stay
with fish for a long time but going away
from fish if we look at the size of the
economy and we look at how much is
churned as turnover the turnovers of all
these all these industries are global
turnovers these estimates were done by
colleagues at deutsche bank and they
estimated this is a couple of years back
when we did the report but it's probably
not that far away now I since the
recession global automobile sector about
two trillion dollars of turnover so
that's the value that we consume us
buyers of cars place on cars and add
that up and they get two trillion
dollars the value of steel placed on
steel by whoever by steel the value of
IT software services of out of trillion
dollars and then a study done in
cambridge by some scientists and
economists estimating the total value of
the global if you like conservation
business the total 10% of land mass
which is in 100,000 plus conservation
areas produce ecosystem services
according to their estimates of the
order of four and a half to five
trillion dollars so if you like thats
value that is consumed by us human
beings as well in some form or the other
but not paid for because these products
of the protected areas once again our
public goods and services we don't pay
for them there's no market so you can't
measure it precisely as you can all of
the other things I just mentioned
similarly we compared capital in other
words the capital invested in these and
again it's trillions of between two
hundred billion dollars for the IT
services sector small to as much as two
trillion dollars for the automotive
industries and this is an estimate based
on
in fact a four percent discount rate so
people might question that as to why
that is that is a good answer but that's
an estimate based on a a relatively high
discount rate of the natural capital
value that resides in these protected
areas and if you look on the right hand
side the number of people employed
globally across these sectors you come
to a startling recognition that the
answers these are direct employees by
the way as indirectly making cars and
factories are directing making steel
involved in steel companies either sort
of head counts of the major companies in
this sectors or six million people of
directly writing software and advising
on software and if you look at the the
estimates and they were very few
available on the total number of people
employed in protected areas largely
government employees the largest
estimate was 11.3 so I've gone a bit
conservative said well let's say 1.5 at
least not more than 1.5 million across
the world and then the question is is
this sensible I mean is there an
opportunity here waiting if we have
valuable services which do deliver value
to society public investment should be
about investing in public wealth there
is public Wealth's tied up in these
protected areas they are delivering
value to society why don't we spend more
as an employee more people to do that
protection well why I have protected
areas where you have in some parts of
the world one person per you know 1,000
square kilometres and how is that one
person supposed to know what's going on
in is 1,000 square kilometers of dense
forest it's an absurdity even smaller
areas i'm familiar with a particular
part outside my home town of bombay
where i spend a lot of time when i visit
they have 100 guards to look after 100
square kilometres long is the city of
eighteen million people you can come in
steel take convert to whatever the hell
you like that one person is not likely
to find you even even one square
kilometer so having a million points
something of them to cover ten percent
of the earth's surface sounds a little
bit like an underestimate of the
capacity the human capacity that you
need to manage these areas which of
course brings you to the point that
because they are public goods and
service providers they are not valued
and that's the reason why they are under
invested it follows so another argument
I would give is that we need to look at
the productive and employment potential
whether you're looking at the product
potential of fisheries around the world
whether you're looking at the employment
potential of protected areas around the
world you need to look at that and once
again there is some good news in India
the National Rural Employment Guarantee
Act has created by paying poor people
off season 100 rupees which is like two
dollars paying people to look after
their local ecology rebuilding forests
building small earthen dams basically
manual labor to fill up the labour gap
within between the the agricultural
seasons they've actually created
something like an ongoing 30 million
additional jobs every year during off
season which is a great example of
rebuilding natural capital paying people
not a huge amount if you had it all up
how much it is but actually achieving
reconstruction of natural capital and
rewarding people for it I want to close
with a quick look at reporting because
very often we talk a lot about solutions
and we don't talk about what we measure
and unfortunately it is my view that
what we do not measure we do not manage
and if we look at this example of some
measurement that was done in corporate
reports now these reports were done for
us by pride Price Waterhouse as part of
the team study and they asked a very
simple question they took the hundred
top companies interrogated their their
annual reports on the left hand side and
interrogated their csr or their
sustainability reports on the right hand
side and asked the question is
biodiversity and ecosystems an important
strategic issue and asked also asked the
question is it at all relevant to your
company so if you look at the annual
reports only two of them out of 100 said
it's an important issue because they
were agricultural companies and
eighty-two percent said irrelevant or
didn't have any mention of these words
but the same companies CSR reports or
sustainability reports had nine
companies saying it's important
strategic issue and only forty-two
percent saying it's not mentioning it at
all and the question comes to my mind
how is it possible for the same company
to deliver such completely different
answers to the same exact question yeah
from two different reports published at
slightly few months away I mean
sustainability report probably published
on Christmas Eve so that you know you're
nicely drunk before you read it and and
the any report published when I read is
an analyst read it and decide
buy or sell so clearly there is
something happening here it is not very
professional and the answer is to me
this is the answers one report you need
to have all this reported in the same
time at the same place as your your
annual reports and in fact that is one
of our key recommendations on the
business side we do ask for move towards
estimating externalities of corporations
and disclosing them just as a way you
disclose directors bonuses or disclose
post balance sheet events or disclose
contingent liabilities there's a lot of
stuff that we disclose in our annual
reports which is not required for palin
balance sheet and P&L purposes but it's
useful because some stakeholder group
has asked for it and today there are
lots of tools available so the excuse of
oh it's too difficult we can't measure
is of course teeb on the economic side
but there's any number of technologies
and of late there's even a WBC SD a
World Business Council report that has
come out on ecosystem service valuation
in fact the problem is the other way
round we have just too much too much
available for businesses but nonetheless
what we are saying is that businesses
should focus on these first four points
which is try to measure what you are not
at the at present managing it will
encourage a creation of em is a creation
of management process around the
company's impacts on nature and it will
help in the in the long run to control
those impacts and to manage them now we
are also asking companies to engage with
businesses and try and extend their
influence and and make the government's
aware that when companies are interested
I think at the end of the day this is
also about recognizing new realities
because we are in a space in at a time
ladies and gentlemen where the world is
much more complicated than it was 50
years ago or 100 years ago we are
operating in a space which has human
capital natural capital and physical and
financial capital all as part of what
corporations use to add value and what
governments have to manage to increase
value for us as citizens and then we
have to ask is are are the metrics that
we are using are the toolkit that we are
using sufficient it's almost as if we
are trying to navigate a three
dimensional space we need something like
a space
ships bank of panels but what we have
instead is a simple Mariners compass and
that's the problem with looking at
simple things like today's pnl account
cell balance sheet or looking at GDP
growth as a measure of national economic
performance and success these are just
far too simplistic is not going to be
sufficient to do that we need to look at
more and better metrics and I think that
also is very much what teeb is about so
I think replacing as I call our
antiquated economic compass before it is
too late thank you very much indeed